foreign
San Antonio Texas hi Carlos how are you
hi how you doing thanks for having me
sure what's up well
um I live abroad I live and work abroad
I'm finally back in the U.S after about
four years I was stuck because of covid
um so about a year and a half ago I sold
my house while I was abroad and I wanted
to now finally use the money and invest
and make it work for me
um now I've been back in the US for
about two years I have a meeting with a
friend who's a banker and we're going to
talk about possible Investments but I
have a friend who bought a piece of
property in Thailand for about 30 30 000
in cash and I was thinking about doing
the same thing so I might actually be in
Thailand in about the next three weeks
or so to take a look at some things
um it's just the first time I've had a
quite a chunk of change in the bank with
uh and being debt free so I was looking
to do something with that
what is the size of the chunk of change
290 000. okay and what do you make a
year
uh
uh I would say about 80
000 but I pretty much live uh for free
not not for free but it's fair the cost
of living is very low I gotcha yeah
um
I would not buy that
okay and I'll tell you why
because there's a bazillion
thirty thousand dollar Investments to do
in the United States and
um the Thai economy is excellent uh it
is a fairly stable situation but there
is not any
um
any close to any country in the world
that is as stable and predictable an
environment as the United States
and when I buy Investments I want stable
and predictable
and um the thing that we forget As
Americans is is that uh you know every
so often some of these countries just
blow up and I'm not predicting
Thailand's gonna blow up that is not
what I said okay but we're just not used
to the uh volatility of government the
volatility of things
um and for you have to have a
predictable environment for economics to
work that's why Law and Order order
versus the opposite of order is chaos
and so when you have chaos you do not
have a predictable environment and
business and Merchants and transactions
cannot occur predictably that's why the
inner city in some of these wonderful
American cities have just been destroyed
because they've lost the uh they've lost
order they've turned to chaos and that's
a miniature version of it happening to
an entire country so uh I I would
instead have my money Stateside uh than
than doing your very first investment in
10 or 20 of your whole net worth is
going to be in a less predictable
environment that's a kind easy way of
saying it so you can do it if you want
to but I wouldn't that's my reasoning I
wouldn't do it not no you and I have
both traveled all over the world yes and
it's easy to
when you're when you're traveling it's
also easy as an American to say okay
everywhere operates the same way and it
doesn't no it doesn't and you kind of
get enamored with these places it's like
oh what this would be so nice and you're
seeing beautiful it's beautiful exactly
I I just think that with real estate
especially it sounds like he's a guy
that hops around he likes to travel it
just feels like
not the move I'm with you I would invest
Stateside it's an environment that you
probably know a little bit more about
not to mention his buddy the banker gave
him the advice which no he was meeting
with him later about meeting with the
bank okay because I was like I don't
know if I let my banker tell me that I'm
not gonna like my buddy that my banker
tell me anything about Investments okay
Bankers are where you deposit money not
where you go for investment advisor
that's right so uh anyway so that's the
second part of the equation you didn't
ask Carlos but I would go to an actual
professional broker that gives people
advice not a banker there's a difference
there's a substantial difference but the
way their brains work so yeah if you
want to find out who we recommend for
that just click on Smart investor at
Ramsay Solutions and you'll find someone
that is a professional that knows what
they're doing that
um that it does investing for a living
and works with giving advice for a
living and that kind and that's who I
that's who I have in my corner and Jade
has in her corner so but uh so that's
the second part of unsolicited advice
here so well he was on the right track
wanting to pay cash but you know that
that yeah he is and that does Parlay I
mean I'll continue that conversation
um
the uh I was thinking about this other
day one of my buddies was all torqued
out about all the Anarchy stuff and all
the the protests and people burning
stuff down he was just he's going nuts
his brains you know he's all he's all
he's spending way too much of his
calories on it because he hasn't got
anything to do with him really but but I
was trying to explain to him it's it's I
thought
um I mean the weird thing about Anarchy
is
if it works you burn everything to the
ground and there's nothing left
that's the purpose of Anarchy is chaos
to destroy every known existing
institution okay and so when you do that
100 of the time what happens after that
another group of Institutions rise up
and they start ruling and the anarchists
are now in charge of that which is the
actual Paradox of Anarchy yeah so I mean
and the problem with all that idea is
that in the process of doing that you
destroy you know what's happening on a
miniature level as I said where you do
not have a predictable environment of
order versus chaos you cannot do
business so in other words let's just
put it into basic terms uh Little Couple
has saved up money they got forty
thousand bucks and they want to open an
ice cream shop okay they are not if they
have wisdom going to open an ice cream
shop in an area that regularly kicks in
the windows and steals everything
because they're putting their stuff at
risk right and so if you want to make
sure that your area has absolutely no
business investment
which leads to Prosperity because it
leads to employment
if you want to make sure your area has
that then just remove order
and insert chaos because you will
guarantee the failure of prosperity in
the area because it's a natural thing
for you people to say I'm not going to
open my ice cream shop where people are
going to burn it absolutely I mean it's
silly you know and and some of these
cities the inner cities are not coming
back after these riots they're just
sitting down there boarded up and that's
why because people lost the belief that
there was order instead they have a
belief that there's chaos so when
someone says Law and Order sometimes
people think oh well that means the
police are just kicking people and
hitting people that isn't what it means
at all Law and Order means that there's
a law
an order is kept as opposed to chaos and
that's not a racial decision that's not
a defund the police decision it's none
of those things at all it's simple that
you cannot have economic prosperity in
areas where you do not have a
predictable environment and so you've
got to and the same thing happens in
your personal life you have to create a
predictable environment so if all you
and your wife your husband do is fight
all the time
very seldom are you going to prosper
because you're in the middle of chaos
all the time and you don't have a
predictable environment so it's very
difficult to invest in believe in and
pour your life into something called a
future because all you're dealing you're
burning all your calories dealing with
the toxic mess that is in your house
and so it can be in your house it can be
in your town it can be in your country
but order is essential to prosperity and
and that that's what I was trying to
explain to my buddy who's drunk the
Kool-Aid of some right-wing crazy butt
stuff but um you know it's a very simple
thing and it's not a main thing and it's
not really even a moral judgment it's
not a uh uh you know what do we do about
it
yeah what do you do about but you got to
have order
and if you don't have order then you're
not by definition ultimately going to
have Prosperity I hear what you're
saying Dave it has to be a predictable
environment and so that that's the thing
and Investments business Investments
where jobs come from uh you're not going
to have the low couples not gonna open
their ice cream store and that just
tells you what's happening and so that's
what's weird is if you burn your own
neighborhood down
that's what you're doing to yourself